Hello, this is 6 Minute English
from BBC Learning English.
I'm Phil. And I'm Georgie.
In the words of a famous 1960s
pop song, breaking up is hard to do.
Divorce - when a married couple who no
longer want to be together separate -
can be one
of life's toughest experiences.
During the 1990s,
divorce rates in Europe and America
were the highest in the world,
with almost half
of all marriages ending in divorce.
But since then,
the trend has reversed, and divorce
rates in the West have slowed.
Meanwhile, however,
the number of couples divorcing in
other parts of the world is on the rise.
In this programme,
we'll be hearing how divorce is
talked about in different countries,
and as usual, we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary.
But first,
I have a question for you, Georgie.
In Britain, one day of the year in
particular is known by divorce lawyers
and relationship counsellors
as 'Divorce Day'.
But which day is it?
a) Christmas Day?
b) the first Monday of the new year?
or c) Midsummer's Day, the 24th of June?
I think 'Divorce Day' is
the first Monday of the year.
OK, Georgie, we'll find out
if that's the correct answer
later in the programme.
Getting married very young
and differences between partners'
backgrounds or interests are two
common causes for couples to grow apart.
Today, Marina Adshade is a professor
at the University of British Columbia
who studies the economics of sex
and relationships.
But her life has
a very different beginning,
as she told BBC World Service
programme, The Global Story.
I married really young.
I had no education.
I married somebody who was older
than me, who had a lot of education,
and our relationship worked well
for a while.
And then in my late 20s,
I decided to go back to school.
I no longer wanted to be
a stay-at-home mother,
which was what I was doing in my 20s.
And that change in our situation for us
just became completely unresolvable.
And I think this is true
for a lot of marriages
because people's situation changes
over their lives.
Maybe they want children,
then maybe they change their minds.
Marina started her married life
as a stay-at-home mum, a woman
who stays home to take care of the
children and manage the household.
Marina married an older man, and although
their relationship started well,
over time, they developed different
ideas about what they wanted from life.
Marina and her husband
changed their minds -
they changed
an earlier decision they had made.
Growing apart is one of the most
frequently given reasons for divorce,
and eventually Marina
and her husband's problems
became unresolvable, not able
to be fixed or satisfactorily ended.
Marina's experience is typical of
someone who finds themself trapped
in a marriage
that no longer works, yet,
unfortunately
due to economic or emotional reasons,
many people stay trapped.
So, what can be done?
Now, some countries are looking
to the authorities rather than
the couple themselves
for a solution.
Here, Lucy Hockings, presenter of
BBC World Service's The Global Story,
and divorce counsellor Joanna Gosling
discuss a new strategy
being used in China.
There was an interesting thing
they did in China
where they introduced this
cooling-off period.
So, the government enforced this.
Does that work when the government
intervenes in a situation like this
and makes people behave or do things
in a certain way?
If nothing changes in the dynamic
between two people, being told
that they've got to cool off
and wait a bit longer,
I don't think is going to make
them suddenly realise
that they want to be together.
It might be an idea
for states to invest
in communication programmes
for these couples,
because that's invariably
why relationships fall apart.
In response
to rising divorce rates, in 2021
the Chinese government introduced
a 30 day cooling-off period
for couples wanting to separate.
A cooling-off period is
a period of time
in which two groups who are arguing
can try to improve the situation
before taking further action.
However, it's unusual for governments
to intervene - to become involved -
in people's private lives this way.
Joanna doubts a cooling-off period
will work, especially
as the main reason for relationships
failing is non-communication.
She says a lack
of communication is invariably
- or always - the reason for divorce.
On the plus side,
by communicating openly,
maybe with the professional help
of a relationship counsellor,
saving a marriage is possible.
I think it's time you reveal
the answer to your question, Phil.
You asked
about 'Divorce Day' in Britain
and I guessed it was the first Monday
of the new year.
Good guess Georgie,
because that's the correct answer.
'Divorce day' is the first Monday
of the year.
OK, let's recap the vocabulary
we've learnt in this programme,
starting with 'stay-at-home mum',
a phrase for a woman who stays home
to care for her children
and manage the household.
If you change your mind,
you change an earlier decision
you made or opinion you had.
If a problem is unresolvable, it cannot
be satisfactorily solved or fixed.
A cooling-off period is
a period of time
for two people to try
to resolve their differences.
It can also mean
an agreed length of time
in which someone can change their mind
about something they've agreed to buy.
To 'intervene' means to become involved
in a difficult situation
in order to improve it.
And finally,
the adverb 'invariably' means always.
Once again, our six minutes are up,
but remember to join us again next time
for more trending topics
and useful vocabulary.
Goodbye for now.
Bye.